jason asks
how can a public or government
institution use social media more
effectively in marketing campaigns i.e
to increase voter turnout
jason
jason the truth to that answer is
believe it or not is to become more
nimble and authentic there is no
campaign
when when there isn't the right process
up top what i mean by that is a lot of
government institutions um
are coming from the wrong place for
example i i know that you know just from
little politics i don't talk politics
very often but like that the democratic
party wants more voter turnout and the
republican party historically has not
these are little tidbits i've picked up
in the last 12 years and i could be
wrong by that they're just people in the
game that i've heard things like that
so where are you coming from is really
the question i mean to use social to
attract more voters the truth is whether
you're republican or democrat you're
trying to not recruit more voters you're
trying to recruit more voters that are
going to vote for you
right and so
right there by its own definition you've
got an interesting kind of
perplexed situation that the seed is
tainted by the outcome and so
to the best of one's ability i think
it's important to
try to get the religion at the top to
really execute i mean look
social media is probably the most
consumer insight driven marketing tool
we've ever seen the data that you can
apply on top of social to drive the
results whether to get somebody to vote
for an election to buy a cat to whatever
it may be
there's never been anything greater and
so
um using i've said it before facebook
dark posts
um
with a combination of google long tail
search sem
can get you very very very far